ARE GOING TO PAY FOR IT IS
ANOTHER PART OF MARKET ANXIETY.
>> Chris: OTHER THAN THAT,
EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
AS CONGRESS TRIES TO PASS THE
BUDGET DEAL AND AVOID THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, SPLITS
EXPOSED AMONG TOP DEMOCRATS.
PETER DOOCY HAS THE STORY OF
NANCY PELOSI VERSUS
CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> TOP TWO DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
BOTH GAVE THEIR INPUT TO
REPUBLICAN COUNTERPARTS WRITING
THE SPENDING DEAL.
THE LEFT SIDE OF THE TABLE LEFT
THE TOXIC SPLIT.
SENATE LEADER WANTS PEOPLE TO
VOTE YES.
>> IT WILL BE EASY TO SAY I
DIDN’T LIKE THIS.
I DIDN’T LIKE THAT.
BUT THIS IS THE TIME TO COME
TOGETHER.
>> THE HOUSE LEADER SAYS SHE’S
GOING TO VOTE NO.
>> I’M NOT PLEASED WITH THE
PROCESS.
>> LOYAL HOUSE DEMOCRATS
FOLLOWING HER LEAD.
>> I SUPPORT WHAT NANCY PELOSI
SAID AND THEN GOING TO VOTE
AGAINST IT.
>> ON THE SENATE SIDE, SOME
DEMOCRATS AREN’T SURE WHY PELOSI
IS DITCHING HER OWN DEAL.
SPEAK WE CAN’T CONTROL THE
DISCUSSION IN THE HOUSE.
I’M SURE THERE’S GOING TO BE A
VARIETY OF OPINIONS IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> SENATE MINORITY LEADER
SCHUMER SALUTED PELOSI’S EIGHT
HOUR PROTEST OF A DEAL HE STILL
SUPPORTS.
>> LEADER PELOSI SHOULDN’T HAVE
TO STAND AND SPEAK FOR EIGHT
HOURS.
I RESPECT HER FOR DOING IT.
>> PELOSI STRESSES SHE’S GOING
TO VOTE NO BECAUSE HER LETTER
SAYS "WE HAVE ALWAYS SAID
NOTHING IS AGREED TO UNTIL
EVERYTHING IS AGREED TO.
EVEN HOUSE DEMOCRATS WHO SAY
DACA ISN’T THEIR BIGGEST
PRIORITY ARE BACKING THEIR
LEADER.
>> WHAT I AM SAD ABOUT IS NOT
NANCY.
I’M SAD WE HAVEN’T HAD A CHANCE
TO VOTE ON THIS.
MY HOPE AND MY JOB IS TO COME TO
THE FLOOR AND VOTE.
>> REPUBLICANS WATCHING THE
DISSENT AMONG DEMOCRATS AND THEY
SEE IT AS HELPFUL IN THEIR QUEST
TO KEEP CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
>> THIS IS A CHALLENGE SHE HAS
DECIDED SHE WANTS TO STAY IN THE
MINORITY ON, THE DACA FIGHT WHEN
THE SENATE IS MOVING FORWARD.
WE HAVE BIPARTISAN AGREEMENTS TO
REACH A SOLUTION AND SHE HAS
DECIDED IT IS WORTH STAKING THE
ENTIRE CAUCUS ON.
>> A COUPLE WEEKS AGO,
REPUBLICANS PEGGED THE LAPSE IN
GOVERNMENT FUNDING AS THE
SCHUMER SHUTDOWN.
THIS TIME SCHUMER IS ON THEIR
SIDE.
PELOSI IS EXPECTED TO BE THE
LONE LEADER VOTING AGAINST THE
SPENDING DEAL.
WE WILL SOON FIND OUT IF THAT